biden's luck ran out that's the subject
of tonight's waters words biden's always
been a lucky guy his whole political
life he won his senate seat because a
union strike just happened to knock out
his opponent's mailings during the final
week
then obama plucked him out of a useless
heap of senators to become vp
the 2020 dem field was so weak all he
had to do to win the nomination was not
be a crazy socialist trump was
positioned to smoke him before covet hit
the virus scrambled the race and gave
frail joe the perfect opportunity to
hide before election day and claim he
was just following the science then the
liberal media blacked out the republic
october surprise hunter's laptop
biden's china connections totally
ignored
a new book
claims the biden family owns slaves
genealogists uncovered evidence that
joe's ancestors on his dad's side held
black slaves here in the 19th century
the media brushed that aside before the
election also that one would have really
hurt
but mail ballots gave biden the win
installed into office by very powerful
forces with the wind at his back he had
warp speed vaccines a recovering economy
a secure border no inflation low gas
prices and trump was off twitter plus
house and senate majorities in a sedated
media
the coast was clear
but joe's luck ran out never being an
executive his entire life joe froze he
couldn't handle the pressure everything
around him began cracking and he's
officially lost control of the country
and even his own agenda is marquee 2
trillion build back better welfare plans
dead this year mansion killed it and it
probably won't be coming back
inflation's ravaging the nation costing
the average family an extra thirty five
hundred dollars this year
only seventeen percent of americans say
they're better off now compared to last
year this is according to a fox business
poll 81 percent say not so much
inflation is the top issue in the
country but all democrats carry on about
is january 6th
the border is wide open meanwhile
illegals bringing in drugs crime and
covid another massive caravan heading to
america right now
cbp just seized over three million of
meth at the border just in two days
alone
you have scenes like this every single
day cartels get rich while american
wages get wiped out because biden's
destroyed the dollar
don't ask kamala about it though she's
really busy
redesigning her office
looks beautiful
how can we get back to work
covered cases are back up after biden
promised he'd shut it down but kovitt is
here to stay so plan accordingly
if you don't like your dumb governor
slapping mandates and lockdowns back on
you move to texas or florida if you can
everybody else's
there's a permanent pandemic in the blue
states
along with high crime taxes and gas
prices
does biden actually believe in this
environment the democrats are going to
win
i believe we're going to win let me say
this again for the president we're going
to win in 2022.
not even cnn says that the left-wing
network admitting every single indicator
is pointing to a landslide victory for
the republicans in 2022. even the new
york times columnists are telling biden
not to run
nearly a third of democrats agree with
him
democrats want someone else besides
biden in 2024.
when the wall street journal asked
kamala harris if biden's running for
reelection in 2024
the ever so loyal kamala just said she
and biden have never really talked about
whether he's going to run again
all she had to say was yeah he's running
because that's what he said he's running
but she left him hanging
left the door open to him not running
joe
you hear footsteps they sound like heels
all kidding aside of course president
harris is a proud howard alum
but if you ask nancy joe he is just
perfect
our country could not be more
could not be better served than with
this most experienced capable hands than
yours president biden
[Applause]
he's just perfect
when nancy pelosi calls you perfect
you're about to get a knife plunged into
your back
summer even now floating hillary is a
name for 2024 saying she'd be the best
option
it's laughable when crooked's your best
option not even god can save this party
joe and all his liberal rats are burying
themselves and luck's not going to save
him anymore time's up
they're done hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else